Yo
là je de filmer mes vidéos là c'est
comme mon sel bien rapide.
Il y a quelque chose catché il y a pas
longtemps là. Ça a été je catché c'est
hyper simple que tout le monde parle
mais que c'est pas intégré pas tout. Pas
du tout c'est pas intégré.
Tu as pas le choix de starter à une
place que tu es pas bon pour
t'améliorer.
Tu as pas le choix. Puis c'est en le
faisant de plus en plus que mé tu vas
devenir bon. Puis c'est complètement
normal. Puis tout le monde le sait.
C'est juste que le monde il ils l'ont
pas intégré. Ils ont pas intégrer le
fait de
tu es nul au début,
tu t'améliores puis tu vas bon.
Le monde pense trop court terme. Faut
que tu a ta vision long terme que tu
t'implantes à toi-même.
Tu l'implantes. Faut que tu l'intègres.
Il faut que tu intègres la vision long
terme. Faut que tuintègres ça.
Tuintègres la vision long terme avec
la discipline d'agir de manière
constante, constamment, de tout le temps
le faire de manière disciplinée. Par
exemple, on prend l'exemple des vidéos
YouTube. Je des vidéos YouTube mais je
dire vous voyez mes vidéos là c'est je
mets mon en plus c'est genre un iPad que
je filme. C'est un iPad, un vieux iPad.
Il y a genre 5 6 ans, la qualité est
vraiment pas bonne. Là, je filme sur mon
sel. Probablement que la qualité est un
peu meilleur
mais j'ai pas assez de place sur mon
sel. Fait vous comprenez que le setup il
est vraiment pas optimal mais on s'en
fout bien. C'est pas ça l'important.
L'important c'est pas de
de starter au top, tu sais, de comme il
y en a là c'est c'est ça que j'avais en
tête pendant vraiment longtemps parce
que les vidéos YouTube c'éit quelque
chose que je voulais faire pendant
longtemps
mais c'est comme si je me sentais pas
prêt puis tout ça. J'avais pas assez les
connaissances tu sais. J'avais pas assez
d'expérience en montage. J'avais pas
d'expérience assez en ce que je voulais
dire. J'avais pas la
j'avais pas la euh comment on pourrait
dire ?
J'étais pas légitime. Je me considérais
même pas moi-même légitime de me filmer
puis montrer ça.
Mais
c'est ça le point que je vais amener,
c'est genre start. Commence à faire de
quoi ? Commence à faire de quoi ?
Mets-toi une routine
de publication pour des vidéos YouTube
une une routine de call des suis des KPI
de je dois faire x nombre de telle
répétition de peu importe par semaine
puis sur le long terme tu vas y arriver
tu vas y arriver tout le monde a pas le
choix de passer par un stade c'est qui
est nul
d'en faire énormément jusqu'au point que
c'est ça serait comme il dit
tu élimines le hasard le volume élimine
le hasard donc commence nul faisant
énormément de manière disciplinée puis
un mané ben tu vas devenir pas pire pué
tu vas devenir moyen. tu vas devenir
correct. Bon puis c'est là que le monde
vont faire crime dans le fond. E tu
l'avais quand même finalement mais tu
l'as pas eu de même. Tu l'as eu en
faisant du volume
puis je à dire rien que ça je sais pas
mais je si vous découvrez mes vidéos
comme c'est pas travailler. Ben c'est ça
le but. Le but c'est pas que mes vidéos
soient le plus travaillé au monde. Le
but c'est vraiment que je fasse du
volume, que je fasse
le plus de vidéos possible
comme ben pas le plus le plus de vidéos
possible, c'est de tofer un une
discipline de publication
le plus longtemps possible.
Puis moi, je vais sur le plus longtemps
possible. Puis je me dis
que moi pour que je le plus longtemps
possible, faut que j'élimine les euh ce
qui est le plus lourd, le plus plat à
faire. Donc faire du montage, de
l'écriture,
de la répétition de
Oh, je parle de quoi ? Je l'arrête, je
la starte et je monte là, je fais le
montage, je mets une vidéo, je mets des
un motion design puis tout. ça va venir
plus tard. Mais pour commencer, c'est
pas ça le
premier point que je dois faire. C'est
pas ça. Le premier point, c'est juste
faire du volume puis on s'améliore de
plus en plus, devient plus à l'aise
devant la caméra puis la donc euh je
peux donner un conseil.
Trouve-toi un objectif que tu veux faire
dans les 90 premiers prochains jours
et abon un plan. Tu peux l'élaborer avec
chat GPT Open
Claud importe. Tu la un plan
suisle
W puis tu vas
cé pas prévu c'est vraiment mais bonit
que
fait quoi de ta vie Yep.